ladies and gentlemen you may have heard
if you've been reading the papers lately
you may have heard illusionist David
Blaine's name in the news he's been he's
been being talked about lately in his
latest stunt David Blaine hung upside
down over New York's Central Park for 60
hours before attempting what he called a
dive of death
now some people question the legitimacy
of this stunt though Blaine claimed it
was his most difficult feat yet well we
wanted to see David Blaine's latest done
for ourselves we didn't want to just
take the media's word for it so the
other night at 3 a.m. we sent our good
friend and trusted correspondent triumph
the insult comic dog with David Blaine
and his son here where the government is
trying for serving an incredible test of
endurance as David Blaine is attempting
to hang for 60 straight hours without
entertaining a single person you saw the
72 hours in the ice the seven days
underwater yeah
the 35 years without anyone liking him
the fascinating stunt everybody Harry
Houdini called this stunt the dangling
douchebag
people are worried that him hanging
upside down could make him go blind
imagine not being able to see all the
people out here giving him the finger
how do you think he's holding how's it
hanging hang in there we should hang out
sometime the South is so lame I want to
hang myself career is hanging on for
dear life now what's going on right now
he appears to be right-side up
that's not exactly the stunt that's
advertised alive you can turn them
upside down again what's happening
anyone who studied the works of Houdini
knows that the hardest part of Houdini
stunts was the 15-minute coffee for him
[Applause]
can he pull off this 15-minute coffee
break about the next one this is
incredible
we are 12 minutes and Counting on
Blaine's coffee break with the kids
watching this right now please do not
try this at home the coffee could be
exceedingly hot and could burn your
thumb please I beg of you this is a
professional he's catheterized I hear do
you think he's peeing right now you
peeing right now is that a thumbs up
thumbs up it's an incredible stunt he's
not only hanging upside down he's also
picking up plants go for it he's
received the phone number and now he's
going back up this is the part of the
stunt fetta Houdini used to call the
human dingleberry
I have buried a nice
[Music]
triumph lane will bury myself in ice and
then I will take a 20-minute break and
then bury myself I am buried in ice I
will be doing this stunt for the next 5
min and then I will have a Frappuccino
how does it feel to be here at this
moment it's it's fantastic I want to see
the dog upside down a challenge I think
we can pull that off you think I can
pull that off me upside down okay we'll
give it a shot
[Laughter]
[Applause]
time for a break what do you got for me
what we got to give the audience
something spider-man the audience is
asking is begging for it
[Applause]